is an all-indian basketball team looking
to shock the world Team India Rising is
a team full of the best basketball
players of Indian origin and they're
playing for the second year in the
basketball tournament which is a single
elimination tournament that offers a
grand prize of one million dollars to
the winner the most amazing part about
this team is that these guys are super
impressive on and off the court like
Gokul and notation who is playing with
Jeremy Lin and Taiwan while also getting
a masters at an Ivy League school the
team has doctors software engineers and
entrepreneurs and all of them played
basketball in college or overseas that's
really impressive while they're
obviously looking to take down that one
million dollar prize they have a larger
goal of inspiring the next generation of
South Asian basketball players across
the world